I'm gonna get started because we have a
lot to cover today so the goal with this
talk is we're talk about probability in
statistics who has any kind of
background in probability and statistics
that's how the curiosity great one in
class counts yeah definitely and this is
probably be a different view of
probability in statistics and you've
seen before
hey my goal is to trying to be pretty
ambitious so I'm trying to cover like
basically everything in 90 minutes so
obviously that's a lot and the real
intention is to give you sort of from
nothing to the generalized linear model
which is something we use all time in
statistics this talk obviously is gonna
have to move pretty quickly because of
that but every other session on this
track today coincidentally sort of
overlaps with the things here so if
you're interested in any one of the
things I talked about I know there's an
a/b testing talk after this there's one
on parameter estimation after that and
then there's another one on using stand
for linear models will be using PI mc3
today but you'll see that's all there so
I'll give you a few seconds sort of get
notebooks and everything ready yeah yeah
there is a requirement is actually on
the on here there is a bit of
instructions if you want to install that
so this is Python 3 I it will require
Python 3 for this but there's a
requirement text should hopefully
install it correctly but it should be
Python 3 if it's not specified in there
you're probably right I probably should
have specified a Python 3 yes yeah yeah
yeah
and hopefully yeah I think you're right
I think I did not
all right so yes today's talk we're
gonna go through this series of
notebooks split into three parts the
first part is going to talk so we're
gonna start from the zero that you don't
know anything about probability at all
we're gonna talk about probability and
then from there we're gonna get to what
statistics is and then we're gonna talk
a little bit about what's very important
called parameter estimation and
hypothesis testing and then we'll
introduce the generalized linear model
which is the workhorse of probability
and statistics so and after that you
kind of get a sense of how to actually
apply stats to regular sort of everyday
problems that you'll come across and
yeah okay so let's start so I'm gonna
start with this simple class right here
and one thing I want to point out
there's no point the first the only
thing we're really important here is is
time so there's no importing NP random
or random or any of these libraries
we're just gonna start with everything's
for transparent the only thing that's
gonna make this mysterious is time so we
have this very very simple magic coin
class and we're gonna see why this coin
is so Magic soon I hope and so you can
see it's very simple it just takes when
you know do not leave the podium it just
takes a very it's a very simple thing it
takes an initial it takes an end a value
to initialize the coin with and then you
can flip the coin I call good
statistical coins and when you flip the
coin it just takes time the current time
as an integer and modulo ends that and
if that's zero that's the result you get
right so just to walk through what's
happening there if we get our current
time I see it's you know with time in
seconds from some arbitrary date in 1970
related to UNIX I believe and we turn
then to an int we get an int here and
then if if our n is 2 and we modulo that
by 2 well this is so this is actually a
great example so this number is not the
same right so this modulus 2 would be 0
but clearly at the time when I ran this
notebook if I run it again it's going to
be tonight so there's a little different
every time because we don't see what
time is so we're gonna create this magic
coin and we're going to flip it but
don't look at the result yet okay so
this magic coin is very easy to
understand if it actually is anyone have
any questions so this is there's any
questions about how this coin is set up
because it's not be too complicated but
you should definitely have this coin
should be completely transparent and non
at this point so when we flipped this
coin we get a result and this is where
probability comes in we know exactly how
this coin works the only thing we don't
know is what time it was when we called
flip right there's some sort of state
there in the world that we missed out on
and this is where we need to know
probability we start thinking about how
probability works so the coin can only
be one of two values it can either be
true or false and it can't be anything
else but if I said what is the value of
coin what's your beliefs about the value
of coin true and false is not really a
great set of tools yeah it's fine over
write that it's not really a great set
of tools to work with to describe this
problem right we don't we don't know but
we know something or actually we know
nothing in a way right so we know we
know that we it's either one of those
two things and we really don't know
which of those two things it is so we
can think of probability as this if we
map true to one and false to zero we can
sort of think about probability as a
softer kind of truth value system right
so we don't know the value of this coin
and a good guess for the value of this
result that we have is 0.5 right if true
is 1 and false is 0.5 is right in the
middle and that's literally all we know
about this coin is that we know
basically nothing it could be either one
of those things so this is is it
important I want to sort of impress on
you when you think about 0.5 you think
well Python doesn't have a point 5 type
I value that's not like a boolean thing
this is a boolean type it can either be
true or it can be false but it can't be
0.5 and this is actually a really really
important thing about how probably in
statistics work we make statements about
probability we're talking about
probabilities in our mind okay so it's
true that the result has not a point 5
value 0.5 expresses what we know about
the state of that result in that coin
and so we have this clear picture of the
world and how things work we know
exactly how the magic coin works there's
no randomness out there randomness is
just because we're ignorant about the
current time and so I always think if we
think this way it kind of makes a lot of
probability problems clear so Nassim
Taleb has this famous book called fooled
by randomness right and when we think
about fooled by randomness we think
about this randomness that's like out
there in the world this sort of chaotic
force
but when we think about random this is a
statement about our minds this title
seems much less shocking right so if we
write this to say fooled by the
ignorance of the full nature of the
process is influencing my naive life
this seems quite obvious right when you
think about that way oh yeah of course
another example I always like thinking
about is you know Einstein's favorite
quote about Heisenberg uncertainty right
he says God does not roll dice right and
that's when you think like yeah the
universe can't be random it can't just
be chance but when you think about that
as a statement about knowledge
Heisenberg sort of says well there's a
limit to how much we can know about the
universe right so you could rephrase God
doesn't throw dice to saying something
like you know we can no we cannot
there's a limit to the full intentions
and actions of God that we can know
which is a much more kind of obvious
statement so in general when you're
doing probability statistics and
actually the deeper you get into it the
harder this temptation is to sort of
think of randomness out there we think
of like normally distributed random
variables of all these things and we
think about that as being probability
out there but probability is always in
here and in general when you keep that
in mind you make much less statistical
errors when you're trying to solve
problems okay so now that we have is
loads we can look at the result and
every time you run this it's a little
different which is kind of cool
so this is false and if you all have the
notebook up you can run it and obviously
some of you will get true some of you
get false and now probability it's gone
we know exactly what happened
we know the time was even when we called
flip and we have this results in our
hand so that's sort of the basic idea of
probability is like a single value but
the cool thing is because we mapped
probability to boolean logic we actually
now can start thinking but can we do
other logical thing so as programmers
we're very familiar with boolean logic
to solve all types of problems we've got
naught and in or are like foundational
tools that we use as programmers right
we can use these same tools as probable
lists so in logic we have not and not as
this sort of simple negation and this is
we all know this but let's walk through
it not true is false not false is true
if we want to make this
probabilistically we just say so not in
probability it's just 1 - whatever the
probability of our thing is and this
works perfectly fine for the case where
we mapped probability to directly the
truth right if we just want to replace
boolean sand pie Chthon with
probabilities
it still works just fine right so one
minus one is zero which is false that's
what we want 1 minus 0 is 1 which is
true which is also what we want but now
we get this extra flexibility here we
can say things like 1 minus 0.25 and now
we have a negation so we have this more
powerful negation it's a bit more
flexible that we can use for other
things we also get ant so we have true
and false we know that is false they
both have to be true right true and true
is true and false and false is false
we have a probabilistic and one thing I
should note is these are theirs if we
get in something called conditional
probability which we're not going to
talk about today these definitions just
get a little extra extension to them so
this is the case when two things don't
depend on each other one information
about one doesn't change just know that
you may see variations on this that are
a bit more complex but don't worry about
that for this point so one this is
interim probability we make and is does
multiplication so we can combine two
probabilities that we will see if they
both happened using and which is
multiplication so again this works
exactly the same as truth a regular
truth tables right so true and true is
true true and false is false false and
false is false but again we get this
great extension where we can tell you
I'm not sure and I'm not sure so 0.5 and
0.5 and I get 0.25 so I get this way to
combine my uncertainties in a logical
way
and the last logical tool we have is or
right so of course you can derive XOR
and all these things if you wanted to
but or it's a little bit more
complicated because of the math Manion
so are we know in logic right or is true
or false is true true or true is true
obviously true or false is true and
false or false is false so as long as
one thing is true it's true now in
probability this is actually a mistake
that's common we will make this so they
think ok we did multiplication for and
if we just do or we can add them all up
right the probability of rolling a 6 or
a 5 or a 3 on a dice you just keep
adding this up but what happens in
practice and we don't have time this
ought to go into it is you'll end up
actually over counting if things can't
both happen like flipping a coin heads
rolling a 6 so we need to account for
that so we have this little extra term
here so there's a probability of event a
probability plus the probability event B
minus the combined probability of both
of those events
you don't have to know it deeply why at
this point but just know this is the
actual rule for or and again if we just
replaced boolean and Python with
probabilities and replaced or with this
we it would work out and so we see 1+1
works out because it's 1+1 I blowing
post yeah 1 plus 1 minus the probability
of 1 plus 1 and 1 times 1 right so
that's going to be 1 which is great as
we want it to be and you notice if we
didn't have that term that multiplies
and takes that away we'd be over
counting we get 2 and probabilities are
between 0 & 1 this is a rule that we
have so that would not be good so this
works out and we can see 1 & 0 which is
the same as true or false we get what we
want we get true and of course we get 0
if they're both false and then again we
get this extension where we can really
ask more complicated things what's the
probability of an event that we're point
to 5 short of happening and or an event
that's point 3 we can do the math and we
can get it out and we get an answer for
that ok so these are the basic rules we
can have it so now we have this whole
framework for dealing with uncertainty
okay perfectly on time which is great so
we have this thing we have this random
result and now we can start thinking
about how we can combine all this things
we don't know and this is actually very
powerful tools this you can take this
and if there's a lecture stop now you
can sort of work it out on your own and
solve a ton of problems and we're gonna
see an example of that next so we're
gonna make another magic coin so yeah so
logic this is these are two points I
want to drive home to as well as logic
is how we reason about facts things that
we know for sure and things that we
don't know for sure we use probabilities
and obviously in the real world almost
everything we don't know for sure
there's always some little margin of
uncertainty you're not basically
anything so we're gonna create an poin
and end for this coin is going to be 3
right so that means if the time when I
flip this coin is divisible by usually
visible by 3 we're gonna get true right
last time it was easily evenly divisible
by 2 it was true so it is even so every
third number is gonna be that so we want
to cope with the probability for this
sort of intuitively and this is the
correct answer as well
the intuitive probability for this is
that okay so if I just pick some numbers
one out of every three is gonna meet my
condition so I'm gonna say it's a
one-third probability that I believe
it's true okay is everyone following so
far good so again this is we can go into
deep
philosophical discussion of how we prove
that this is true but in this case your
intuition is right one out of three
events is the one we care about that's
going to be true ok so now we're going
to do something a little bit more
complicated here we're gonna create this
results list okay and we're gonna we're
gonna create this and then we're gonna
append this new magic coin to it it's
gonna flip it one thing interesting is
because it's using time if you put these
all on a single cell and run them at the
same time they'll all be the same
because it all happens at the exact same
time right I was in a second it was far
as Python occurs so when I first built
this out I was like huh why is it always
true or always false and like oh yeah
cuz they all executed under a second but
actually it's a good point about when
you think about the more we know about
how something works the more we can
reason about what we don't know right so
you know if they're all on the same cell
they're gonna be the same so if we wait
a few seconds and if we run this one and
now we have another probability question
okay so this is a bit more complicated
before I just want to know whether or
not the result was true now I want to
know what this Python statement is going
to evaluate to and so we've added two
things to a list and we flipped them at
time so I don't know what times they
were and now we have two results and I
want to know the results that is any
right so we're gonna walk through how
we're gonna reason about this but just
for to think about how much of is this
as minorly more complicated case but
it's gotten a lot trickier to sort of
reason about how confident we are in
that so the probability of true is
one-third we put two what we flip the
coin twice put them in there and if any
of them are true then we're set but we
had to sort of think how this works so
we can think about all the possible
things that could happen in general if
you're not sure where to start
probability counting out the outcomes
you want looking at the outcomes you
care about is a good way to come up with
your probability so again we can prove
that in all kinds of fancy ways but this
is a generally good rule and it's tricky
when you can't count now it comes like
probability of weather tomorrow being
rainy those are a little bit more
sophisticated ways to think about it but
for this we can just list out all the
possible outcomes so these are the
things that could have happened right we
could have true or true false or false
false or true true or false there's four
outcomes and we just need to know the
probability of the ones that we actually
care about which is true true false true
and true false so we can actually use
our logic of looking at this so
we know that the probability of true and
true right so because it's enumerate
through all these look at the
probabilities and we can just use our
basic logic right so we want to know the
probability of true and true right so
it's a Sailaja chol statement we can use
our rules there so the probability of
true and true is one over nine right
because we went through those rules
before it's one-third times one-third
now we have one over nine that's how
sure we are that that outcome happened
then we have the next outcome we care
about which is false so we can actually
go through all of these so we know the
probability of false is just the
opposite of true and we can use the
logic for this to figure out that the
probability of this one is four over
nine okay and again this is if the math
is like boring you over it like 9:30 in
the morning it's totally fine you just
have to remember that this is the we're
just doing the and and ORS and nots that
we just went through the basic logic
there so there's really no like the
equations can make your mind feel very
tired but this is really just the
application of that basic sort of logic
we had and then we have these other two
outcomes that we want which is the true
and false and it's in this flip is gonna
be the same right so this is true and
false in this case we get two ninths and
so we can put the things the things we
outcomes to care about are true true
true false or false true right so those
are the three there's the three outcomes
that we actually care about and we just
know if any one of them happens so one
or the other or the other and since they
can't all happen at the same time we
don't actually have to worry about over
counting so we can add them up and we
get four over nine okay so one way to
look at this is a kid each of the
outcomes we care about and we're just
gonna or all of them and two again and
we get five over nine another way we
could solve this it's gonna say wait we
know the probability of false and false
is four over nine all I care about is
that it's not false over false so that's
gonna be one minus four over nine and it
works at the point I'm showing here is
that this is consistent right you can
express the or of all the possible
outcomes so we care about or the
negation of the outcome we don't care
about and both of those should be
logically consistent and they aren't so
even though there's a lot of sort of
calculation happening here it's really
still boiling down to basic logic which
is pretty cool now we get something
really powerful out of this so let me
just see what the result is because I
always like to see what happened it
happened too great so so this is cool
and let's try
more thing so that was already a lot of
work and we just had two things in our
list so you had two things in our list
and already I can feel like everyone's
brain so I can write this is pretty good
we're gonna make a a more tricky one so
this is our third magic coin and it's
initialized with four so it's gonna be
probability of one over four and we're
gonna flip it and we're gonna flip it
again and again and again and again
alright and so wait what was the idea
here oh yeah so we so I want to see what
the length is right so this is much
trickier so so the question I have is is
how long is I wanna make statements
about how many things are true in this
right so we're going through therefore
each of if it's true it's gonna return
true and I want to see how long that is
right so we're filtering so we flip this
one two three four five times and I want
to know how many times it came out true
right that's my result three so the
question now is what is that number and
this gives really hard really fast right
even though we're just dealing with
these the rules of probability these
logical things is really tricky we can't
go to our old solution where we
enumerate all the outcomes because we've
got a lot of outcomes now even though
it's just five coin tosses right we've
got five things in this array I just
want to know how many aren't true and
how probably how likely that is how
likely is it that two are true so this
is really really tricky thankfully we
have a probability distribution for this
so this we're gonna import scipy eyes
stats and we're going to use this
binomial distribution that they have and
this distribution we're not gonna derive
it from scratch but basically we
actually did so what this distribution
does is it does this work for us we
enumerates the possible outcomes and
then it counts how many truths there
could be and the probability of each of
those right so we're gonna walk through
this distribution binomial distribution
is just a function you can think of it
like a regular Python function that you
tell it the probability of an outcome
happening you tell it how many times you
flip the coin and then it will tell you
for any given input how likely that is
to happen what
probability is for you and it's doing it
the same way we calculated this it's
just that you don't have to do this by
hand anymore so we can see so we so this
was our actually should be one over for
anyway
if we did all this is for this is for
the first example so in this first
example we had n is two right we had two
the previous one we had two things each
one had a probability of one third of
happening we can actually have it do the
math for us and we get this so this is
the same thing as the 4 over 9 that we
expected so this is the probability of
getting no true with 2 this is the
probability of just getting one and this
is the probability of getting two and we
can add these two together so this saves
us doing all the work we did for that
first part so if you did the first part
and thought this is really confusing I
don't anyone do this much kind of
probability you don't have to go over
again now that you've seen how you build
that up you can use the binomial
distribution to do that work for you and
it's really important because we need to
be able to do that to solve the problem
we have now so we're just going to look
at what this looks like or we have five
so this is the distribution for two so
this is what we this is actually what
this is visualizing what this
distribution looks like this is the
binomial distribution for that previous
example we had two coin tosses so the
probability of getting zero one and two
true values in that array now we have
five tosses so this is our problem now
that's why we really need these
distributions because even at five this
problem has become really really hard to
do with pencil and paper it sort of just
think through so we need these tools to
solve this problem for us and we're
going to do this for five give this
distribution plot it out and you can see
what this looks like so this is really
useful because now if I ask you and we
can actually look at it but if I said
what's the probability of getting just
one true value out of that list that was
probably the result three is length one
you can look and go it's gonna be about
point four what is it is it likely that
all five are true no it's almost not
it's not gonna happen right is it more
likely that I have 0 or to all these
questions can be answered with the
distribution which is really useful so
yeah so we can see it was a probability
getting one we get that exactly we can
we can look at if we wanted to know what
the probability of all these sort of
other values right want to know this
greater than one I can get the sum of
all the values greater than one here all
those things so we can sort of start
reasoning much more
in complex ways about this thing which
is really hard to do the probability for
because we have this distribution okay
so this is this is the Bernoulli
distribution that's going to the end of
this part but let me get you to where we
sort of think about difference between
actually on another reason what was one
so this time we got just one so this is
this is where this is probability and so
I think a big thing people question is
the different probability in statistics
and so probability so far we've known
everything we know how exactly how the
magic coin works we know exactly what
parameters are in it it's completely
transparent we just have one tiny piece
of information we don't know but we have
a very clear understanding of how much
we know and what we don't know and so
we're able to do these things and even
though it's a bit of work to do all the
probability we can still work through it
and now that we have tools like the
binomial distribution we can ask all
kinds of questions and sort of get a
better sense of this so this is a
slightly different variation on our
magical coin this magical coin is
initialized with the value that we don't
know what it is so I took the time right
and I made it in the same way the inside
logic does for this I added one to it so
this is non zero so this could be
anything between one and seven is the
value that this coin was initialized
with but we don't know what that is and
so now when I do something like this I
just put three in here it's really hard
to make a guess what's in there because
we don't know anything about the coin
and this is where we actually need to
sort of flip our thinking around so
before we were thinking in purely
probabilistic terms we were asking
questions about what data should I
expect given that I don't know right
what's the probability I get a head or a
true value right what's the probably I
get three those types of questions
all right we know how the machine works
we know how the object works we want to
make it an assumption about how the data
comes now
we're gonna use the data to start making
assumptions about how this models
working and that's what about statistics
work that's why there's the data in data
science because we need data to
understand it without any information
you don't know very much about this coin
at all it could be anywhere from if the
value is one every result out of this
coin is going
be true if the value is 1/7 it's gonna
be very rare to see truth the difference
between 1/7 and one-sixth is not so big
so it's gonna be hard to see and so we
can look at the results in a second but
this is this is sort of the visual I
have 4 for where we are now right and we
have probability we have a very clear
view of the world and we have a very
clear view of what we don't know in this
case even for this very simple example
it's not there's not a lot of moving
parts to this or anything about the
world that we try to learn about as data
scientists or programmers there's a lot
more unknowns going on in this model
there's there's not that many moving
parts but it's still very hard to reason
about you could do that and I have
homeworks at the end of these if you
want to sort of really dive deeper after
the talk but this is where we are now
right we don't even really know what we
don't know we don't even know how we're
going to necessarily tackle that problem
and part of its because the world is
sort of hidden from us and that's the
real life problems we have all the time
right you want to know whether a product
is selling better on your website
there's a lot of information you don't
know about who's viewing that what makes
that product successful what makes
someone buy a product we're gonna do
that in the next section we're going to
look at that a little bit deeper so we
can we can actually look at these
results actually I'm not gonna read
around this one this was an interesting
one so there's one outcome in this magic
coin where if it's one the magic coin
it's always gonna produce the value true
right because anything modulo 1 is going
to be true so if we get these results of
our our new magic coin right there our
new magic results where we don't know
even when it was initialized with this
gives me some evidence that there must
have been one right the value in the
coin it could have been like two or
three probably wasn't one over seven
right probably wasn't seven was of time
I ran the coin app because if that was
the case then it'd be very very unlikely
to get true right we're not gonna do the
math for this but you can start thinking
this is how you start thinking
statistically right given that I saw
this now what do I know about plausible
explanations for what's happening inside
that coin and that's when you think
about how we do business problems right
that's what we're always trying to get
we're trying to get a plausible
explanation for what's happening out in
the world we don't really know what the
world the real world is a much more
complicated version of the magic coin
and what we're trying to do is take the
data from the world and try to interpret
and get a sense of what's happening out
there
and so when we run this again you can
see in this case I'm and you can
intuitively feel this right if you get
this many true results
you can at least you I think everyone
here sort of feels like it should
probably be one because even if it was a
two what's the initial value in there
right it's really unlikely that in in
five in six coin tosses you're gonna get
all heads right you can sort of feel
that you can work it out mathematically
that's what statistics is about it's
actually putting numbers to that but
here we can tell I'm pretty confident
that this is a value of one so the
homework for this if you want to do this
is you can actually just sort of explore
this if you really understand this last
example here this for a statistical
example of the magic coin then you
really understand all statistics so this
seems like a trivial problem but if you
if you sit home tonight and you sit at
home this week and sort of start to
shrink thinking about how this coin
works and trying to unravel it you can
work out the probability from the very
beginning because you look at the
probability of each time you can you can
think of what possible outcomes those
would give you put that all together
it's a very complicated thing it's not
it's not an easy homework but if you
really want to dwell on this and sort of
get an intuition for how probability
works diving into this problem deeper
will really help you and it's hard so if
you feel like wow this is tricky this is
actually tricky and then answering
questions like okay so how many coin
tosses do I need to make a good guess
right and can I know like when it's all
true so we can make that guess pretty
quickly right we know that I'm pretty
sure that that's one inside that coin
and because it's an object in Python you
can actually peek inside right you can
see what that n is and see if you were
right but as you start answering those
questions about how you'd make inference
about that coin that is what statistics
is so that is how we think about
statistics and if you really understand
how you would run tests on that coin to
make a guess how you could differentiate
between whether it's one over whether
it's seven or six which is a really hard
case is there what possible values it
could be how you would do all that if
you can build it all out you basically
understand all statistics in my opinion
you have them really the core part of it
and you don't need any more tools so
what we have right here which is pretty
cool ok perfect timing
halfway through how's everyone doing
does anyone have any questions on this
first part great I really appreciate
when coming here in the morning and talk
about statistics after a conference like
that's really like I'm proud so so now
we're gonna move behind the scenes there
is gonna be some random here but you're
not gonna see it directly and and this
is gonna get into a really important
idea of parameter estimation which is
what we just were sort of talking about
here you'll notice I have a
couple of classes that I developed I'm
not gonna show you how they work because
it's part of reality and real statistics
if you want when you look in the repo
you can actually look how these these
classes are written and sort of see how
they actually work they're not that
complicated they're not much more
complicated than magical but we have a
customer a product and we run an
experiment so the the product class has
it has a quality number between well
it's not in force but it's between one
and five and the examples and it has a
cost those are the two basic things
right so it's a very simple product and
when a customer interacts with the
product they can choose to buy it or not
and they also the customer has internal
preferences for these things and if the
and it's totally deterministic so the
customer that only I oh that's when I
can tailor this when the customer buys
our product in this example it's not
random it's completely deterministic if
you know the internal state of the
customer you can absolutely decide
whether or not they will purchase the
product it's not this randomness out
there all the madness again is inside
our heads because we don't know how this
all works so here's a toothbrush it's an
all right toothbrush cost $4.99 and its
quality is 3.9 now I get it in the real
world this is interesting in the real
world if you have a product you don't
actually get to input what the quality
is right that would be awesome if you
could if you could build a product in
like we're only going to build perfect
claw products that would be great in
this example we have that you do have
control over the price in real life
right so this is where like you even get
when you start using it more and more
statistics don't asking questions about
like what do I even have control over
how can I make this toothbrush do better
but in this case in this happy world we
can choose the quality of our expression
it's alright toothbrushes alright it's
not too expensive and what we can do is
we can take this and we can get a random
customer and again the customer will
deterministically buy this product
they're generated random so this
customer represents if you have a
website or I mean anyone that's doing
anything with people this represents
someone that walks in from the street or
comes to your website randomly you don't
know everything about them right there's
a lot of details about that person and
we're completely ignorant of what those
are when they get there but they are
sampled from a population of people and
they come but this is an actual instance
this person object is an instance of a
person and their preferences are fixed
once they're created and there's nothing
that we don't know what they are but
they are set and we just decide whether
they'll purchase the toothbrush or not
this person did not decide
to purchase a toothbrush so this this is
great right and we don't really know
anything about toothbrushes the funny
thing is about this so is so we revealed
an experiment to do this but depending
where this toothbrush is it's actually
much more complicated than the magic
coin but one of the great sort of
mercies of statistics is that the more
complicated things are the sort of
broader assumptions we could make right
so we're gonna just sort of think about
this as there's gonna be some kind of
rate that people buy toothbrushes right
there's some kind of probability that if
we show a toothbrush to a customer they
will buy it and this isn't thing we do
all the time in real life right I mean I
I work at Wayfair and a huge part of my
life is figuring out what's the
probability that a product will sell if
I show it to a bunch of people and why
so this is and so we're going to think
about that's a very simplifying
statistical assumption right that's the
real reality is this toothbrush has
these thresholds this customer has these
thresholds when they match the customer
purchases it we're not modeling that
that's a lot more complexity we're just
going to make the simplifying assumption
that it all kind of works out in the end
and there's a rate that if we show this
we will sell it so we're going to design
an experiment there's an experiment
class and what this is going to do is
just going to show it to a bunch of
customers so we're gonna run a test
we're gonna get show it to 20 people and
we're gonna try to figure out what is
the rate that this coin cells and then
we're in statistics land now we're gonna
use probability but the first talk is
really the only part that we're strictly
in probability space stuff this part and
here on out we're trying to look into
this object and try to understand how it
behaves and in this case there is no
magic end that we can actually peek at
and tell us how it works
so so we get twenty purchases we can see
some people did some people did not even
looking at this you can kind of make
some intuitive feelings for how well
this toothbrush does or does not sell so
and again this is not like the magic
coin this is it completely this is a
black box right people talk a lot about
black boxes and machine learning and I
think one thing I also like people this
thing but is the reality is actually the
black box it's not neural networks right
the real world is the thing that we
don't really understand and we're trying
to take a stab at it
and this is sort of an example what
we're trying to do so we showed this to
all these people and we can see in this
case that six holed out of twenty so in
obvious first if you saw this
you'd say okay thirty percent of people
will buy this buy this toothbrush right
and that's a pretty good we call that a
statistics a point estimate with a
pretty good estimate but given what
we've seen are there other options right
is there other possibilities and so of
course right I mean we our best guess
right now is point our intuitive guess
is that it's a thirty percent chance to
sell but we could is what if we changed
our estimate by adding 0.05 to it or
subtracting point oh five for those
possible of course they're possible
right but how do we quantify that we
need some sort of way we can say how
possible they are so we think back to
the binomial distribution right we can
say oh actually so if we if we knew
right if we knew this print this
estimate we have this point three right
we know how many people we showed it to
that binomial distribution will tell us
how likely that outcome that we actually
saw was if that was true right so if the
rate is thirty percent and we go back to
probability land where we assume we know
we are correct we are at 30 percent how
likely is what we saw to have happened
and we can now get a number for that
this number in a vacuum isn't super
useful all right is this tells us which
of the possible is what we can do is we
can use this as a tool to compare other
guesses right so if I were to subtract
from my estimate Oh point zero five we
can do the same thing and you can see
it's less likely right if that was the
true rate if less than if if point zero
five less than what we observed what we
our guess is was the true rate then it's
going to be slightly less likely but
certainly not impossible right it's a 20
percent chance was our best estimate but
these other estimates that we have we
can add to as well right so of these
estimates we can see that adding point
zero five to our estimate it's a little
bit more likely to have produced the
data we saw than if we subtracted point
zero five
both of these are fine though so which
one is it right we don't really know and
so this gets to that sort of modeling
our internal state of what we believe so
we have three options here I know my
best option but I don't want to be
constrained to just one possible option
so we could think about this if we if we
if we did this idea right it just okay
let's let's look at the binomial
distribution let's iterate through a
bunch of possible outcomes right so in
this case we're just going by every
point ten guess right like what if it
was twenty percent what
it was 50% we get a distribution that
looks like this right so our 30 our 30%
is that peak right there that's our best
guess but you can see how well every
other guess we could have made described
it so it's really really not possible
looking at this and it's 80% right if I
said I think this brush is great I don't
think is this an OK toothbrush I think
this is amazing toothbrush and people
love it and they really are gonna buy it
at 80% and we just got really unlucky
you would go I don't think that's true
well it's really unlikely that this this
toothbrush is that good and we happen to
get with 20 people this outcome and you
can say yeah but will there's all kinds
all the guesses we could make here right
and so we can do that so we can we can
keep making this more and more
fine-grained all right we get a smoother
and smoother curve and we get beautiful
and you're doing math when you get these
really beautiful smooth curves that's
real life never looks like that so now
you know you must have done something
smart because you got a smooth curve so
this is where we want to be and this
introduces the other distributional use
today which is called the beta
distribution we're definitely not going
to derive how to get there but this is
the intuition behind the beta
distribution the beta distribution is a
very fancy sounding one it has two
parameters it's a little confusing so it
has two parameters which is alpha and
beta and alpha is how many successes you
had so how many true values how many
sold beta is how many you didn't which
means the total is alpha plus beta so
the binomial model right we had how many
successes you had and how many total
when we do the beta we always look at
successes versus failures and we have to
add them together to get the total this
distribution is a continuous
distribution which for all is practical
for this talk this means it goes over
every possible rate that we could have
and it also is scaled a bit differently
so that when we do math on it it all
sums up to one to get a complete
probability but this is basically what
it looks like and this is really useful
because this now remember that sort of
fuzzy image of our brain we didn't know
statistics for this toothbrush problem
this is now the clearer image of our
mental state this is what we actually
believe and when you saw those
toothbrushes you don't necessarily feel
that right when you just see okay I see
I see six old out of 20 I don't know
what I believe this is the correct and
some tweaks we can do on this I don't be
too dogmatic but this is sort of the
correct model of your mind
which is a really useful tool to have
because now you can start doing
quantitative things so this lets us do
oh this is my favorite part of this
actually so normally when you get
introduced to this you have to do
calculus to solve this and everyone's
like having out I don't I don't want to
calculus but because we're all Python
programmers here the best thing is we
can just sample from this okay so this
is we're going to use and we're gonna
use numpy the random beta this will
sample from this distribution that we
have here and say okay so what we do
with that the cool thing is we can just
ask questions about samples and they'll
give us the answers we want which is
really really good and it's not even a
hack it's the way you have to do it when
you get to really hard problems so you
don't have to feel shame for not doing
math you can actually feel like you're a
sophisticated first and doing a Monte
Carlo simulation because you are and if
some math person tells you all you can't
do this by hand you can say no you don't
because once you start getting into real
problems which you'll have a couple of
speakers today talk about and get some
really complicated things you need to
use PI MC or Stan they are doing a very
very very sophisticated version of this
but at the end of the day we can only
solve really hard problems so this is
the way to start thinking start thinking
in terms of samples it's not a cheap
trick it's actually the way we do it
professionally and the cool thing is now
you can encode ask all these great
questions okay so what's the probability
that the rate is actually greater than
then point four right given that I saw
this is it possible that it's much
better than I saw right we saw a 30% is
it could it be 40% now you can actually
put a probability to that so you just
literally like ask that question of the
samples alright how many of these
samples are greater than that how many
samples were there
that's our probability of that happening
that's really cool we're only can solve
that by integrating over the
distribution you don't have to integrate
ever again Nellie here Python and then
of course the nice thing is this is sort
of versus if we look at the samples from
this distribution I put that math in
there because you just got to put some
math in these talks do you feel legit
you can see you can see when we estimate
this right the mean of these samples is
the same mean we came up we do this
empirically which is a sort of a good
sanity check that we take a whole bunch
of samples the average of this is
exactly what we estimated for that and
that's because that is that's what the
math says that the expectation that beta
distribution is alpha over alpha plus
beta which again I'll phosphate is a
total
so just how many you saw over how many
there are it was like a really fancy
mathematical way to say that so if you
like are just averaging over what you
saw you can just show with people that
look like wow very sophisticated okay so
now everyone's favorite thing hypothesis
test this actually what got me into
Bayesian stats because I hate T tests
and I hate p-values and nobody
understands them and people who tell you
they understand them are gonna have
someone else that tells them that they
don't understand them because they're
silly and we're not gonna have any
p-values in this okay so the cool thing
is we already have this great framework
for hypothesis testing so we're going to
just a new toothbrush the luxury
toothbrush this is a great great
toothbrush but it costs more right again
it's nice to be able to control that
quality so the luxury toothbrush is
another toothbrush and it cost more it's
better the thing is you know how is this
gonna perform when we try to sell it the
cool thing is my rotors code I actually
had no idea how this is gonna work like
so even I did not know this is the
answer that's why I actually didn't
sample from distributions for this I
have this actual rule behavior in these
models they're really deterministic
we're deciding things so even I didn't
actually know how this was gonna work I
wasn't like we're gonna sample from a
normal and I know the answer I don't
know the answer I read you now because I
did this talk so our experiment class
has this nice ability to take two
products in and it will run an a/b test
which just means we're gonna show when
we run experiments now rather than
showing one product we're gonna show the
two products the two groups of people
and get results from both there are two
separate groups of people but we just
assume that they're they're you know
randomly distributed from the same group
of customers just random people come in
to the website we show them different
toothbrushes to see how many buy them so
we're gonna do a test with 30 these are
actually kind of fun I'm a crazy gonna
blow up oh you're right but yeah so this
is a chance for 30 we're gonna show it
to 30 customers and we can see you know
we know how it so a the the a purchases
the first argument there is the product
a and the second argument is it probably
to be it's an a/b test there's gonna be
another talk today on a/b testing in
depth so if you like this you can go to
that and get sort of a much deeper dive
into this but here we go we got all
these values for this and we get the
logger toothbrush
looks like it sold a little worse we can
print this out okay so we do we do see
this and this is where parameter
estimation comes in because you might
see that and go out why do I care
about how certainly about to Express
selling if 30% time is fine but this is
where it really becomes important
because now we have these two estimates
and we want to know how likely is it
that I'm wrong right so if I look at
this I say okay the the the cheaper
toothbrush sells a lot better people
don't care about quality as much as I do
price they're much more price sensitive
in their quality sensitive all I care
about
is is I look at this this is I'm done
but that's why we need stitches you
could be wrong if I do this to
toothbrushes you wouldn't believe me
right we only saw 30 we only give to 30
customers do we have enough information
to know are they different enough that
we can so what we can do is we can is
this a lot of stuff for prodding for
running this parrot we can plot this out
so we can plot these two beta
distributions right so each of this the
estimates from the data we got for each
of the toothbrushes so we have the
luxury toothbrushes beta distribution
there and the regular toothbrushes over
there and you can see there's a lot of
overlap right so these are how we
believe about each of these but we can
see our beliefs kind of cross over a bit
and it's not quite we're not quite
certain that all cases of the luggage is
brushed being worse or true right we
have a couple we could it could be
possible based on what we've seen that
the luxury toothbrush really sells at
20% all right and the regular toothbrush
does at ten
those are both pretty reasonable beliefs
there's a lot more obviously than the
other one but we and again if we can
solve this we don't have to do any fancy
math we can run them we can run large
larger tests if we and this is a cool
thing so if we run this larger I mean
actually we get better estimates right
so this is a classic like why is data
important right as we as we add data to
this these estimates get more and more
narrow so we at this time we listed a
hundred people and we can see compared
to this first one this one we're kind of
confused at thirty people if there's a
lot of overlap between these two at one
hundred it starts to separate out quite
a bit there's still that little tiny
area we kind of want to be nervous about
that but again we can do the same thing
with samples right so this is a really
tricky problem we have to sort of look
up two random variables the difference
is that now we don't have to do that we
can just sample and we can ask questions
of the samples and so we can literally
say okay we're using a thousand ten
thousand samples of each of these
distributions that we have and what's
the probability that let me just run
this again yeah so in this case for this
one it's very unlikely right so
because they're quite separated but we
want to put a number on how separated
they are you can't really tell so what
is the real probability that the luxury
is in fact better or the or in this case
I'm gonna look at the probability of you
can look at the code right so you know I
want another probability that the
regular one is better than the luxury
one so you can literally just code that
in you take samples and distributions
and then we get an answer and so if
someone says to you okay we ran this
test 100 people are you sure that the
the regular toothbrush tells more you
can say yeah I'm very sure I'm 99.5%
sure that that's whose brush sells
better and you can really be confident
and you built this whole thing up from
scratch so there's no magical p-value
again I put it in into t-test and it
gave me some p-value and I know what it
means and I hope I did it right you can
reason through all this if we built all
of this up from basic logic we had to
throw in a little extra math for the
beta distribution but now that we have
that we're here and so you can really
feel confident about this and again you
can keep sampling and ask kinds of
questions if you want to know okay but
what about this without you can you can
tweak this a lot and play with it and
you can build any experiment you want
now so the homework for this section is
to sort of - I haven't posts on this
that goes into a bit more detail there's
ways that you can add prior
probabilities to this which is really
interesting I'm not gonna go over that
today the blog posts there does go into
it quite a bit it's actually very easy
to add a sort of prior belief so you
might you might be an expert in
toothbrushes and say will I know that
these luxury toothbrushes are gonna sell
I don't think that hundred is right I
think that this toothbrush has got
supremely unlucky as a toothbrush expert
I recommend you take my advice you can
actually incorporate that into the
estimate which is very cool let's see
where we're at
oh great we actually have a little bit
of time that went faster than expected
the wonderful does anyone have any
questions about this part so far no
questions great Wow so we're gonna
actually succeed at this custody of part
three works
oh is this great okay so this is the
next level up so I had this beer that
day was really good I don't know it just
so generalized linear models like a
robot I don't know so if you've done
enough statistics or talked to enough
statisticians you hear about linear
models all the time
if you're like a neural network person
people like me are always saying have
you tried logistic regression and you
get really annoyed and you go why does
people talk about on your models all the
time is so annoying don't they know that
we have nonlinear models that are very
powerful so if you have a machine
learning background how do you learn how
do a lot of machine learning or any
machine learning okay
yeah any made a lot okay great so you're
probably thinking I know logistic
regression I know any regression will
it's a toy model you use it to show
these things working let me get random
for us and then we just build Ganz and
it's great this is a very different view
of how linear models work and we're
gonna we're gonna think about them quite
differently and we're gonna focus on
different things about them in
protection we don't care about the
predictions which I could write there's
not gonna be any cross validation in
this section and you're gonna the cool
thing is so once you see what you can
use linear models for you like that it's
basically all of statistics I feel
really cheated that I mean it sounds so
hard this is where you will know it also
so yeah we'll get into linear models
right away
I believe so we're gonna import a whole
bunch of stuff okay so in case you're
not familiar with the linear model
everyone who did high school math should
know this should this like should bring
back like terror of like I know I see I
think of algebra oh my god who ever
meant like rise over run intercept
that's the linear model right linear
Molitor says like we've got some slope M
we have an X which is some value we care
about we have some intercept B and
that's a linear model right everything
is a straight line great so we're
actually not gonna use a dot linear
model or like this example so I have a
long post on this really is logistic
regression which is an extension so when
I talk about that you may have heard of
the generalized linear model before you
know what is that all about it turns out
that first off the linear models really
useful and we'll see that a second is
useful in a lot of places and then you
can do a lot more magical stuff with the
linear model by generalizing it and what
that kind of means you just bend it
space so this is if you've used a
sigmoid before logistic regression
you've seen that s right and like
someone probably put a bunch of like
complicated equations and said this is
an S so he forced these valuable that
all it's doing is the exact same paper I
drew that one on is it's bending the
surface that that we're looking at so
underneath you see it's the same
cleaning your model it's just warping
that surface so that's what logistic
regression it that is the generalized
linear model does it looks at a bunch of
different ways we can use a mathematical
function to warp the surface that the
linear model lies on so it behaves in a
very nonlinear way so when you see that
s and you know and it's often just it
always squishes values to one values to
zero one that's not really true you can
actually in the post I have link there
you can derive it from base theorem and
sort of see where it's coming at and
understand exactly where this warping
comes from but another way to think
about it for this example for today's
talk is when one deals probability it's
not numbers that go between negative
infinity and infinity on a straight line
so we're gonna warp the space using a
function we're not gonna go into that
function but that's what's happening so
we're gonna talk about things as if
they're on a straight line but a
straight line is gonna be that one that
I've been right there and we're gonna
use that to do all kinds of analysis
this is just so the linear model works
as probabilities this is logistic
regression and in our case that just
lets us do linear models with
probabilities which is great okay so we
can now think of our problem a bit
differently and this is a pretty cool
thing but this takes a little bit of
like cognitive leap so I'm using like
the high school math notation usually
use betas because it makes you seem
really sophisticated like then we have
the beta distribution it's very
confusing so you'll see all kinds of
variations on how to write this don't be
intimidated by them if people put it in
a format used for matrices it looks
almost exactly the same so it you know
we can assume that these are whatever
this is the high school math version so
we're just trying to predict and again
we're in this bent space so these are
going to be probabilities but this is
how we should think about the problem it
makes a lot easier to decompose so we
just want to think about this okay so
someone purchased it and this is a
logistic regression problem if you don't
logistic regression you can think about
the data this way we have we have an
indicator that it is or is not luxury
right this is like the simplest data
science problem you could think of right
we have a list of someone purchased it
as ry we have a list of whether or not
it's luxury that's not that complicated
of a problem our model is gonna learn is
these two coefficients right M which is
the slope and B is the intercept and
we'll get into how to interpret those in
a second so we're gonna build our
toothbrushes up again and we're gonna
we're gonna this is some code to
restructure them into data frames so
they're sort of your typical data frame
view that you sort of have so if you've
done a lot of linear models or any kind
of
learning work you're very familiar sort
of like columns prediction value of a
bunch of columns okay so oh yeah so we
know the a/b test data it looks like
we've seen this before so this is gonna
be this is PI MC 3 I'm not gonna go into
the details of Pi MC 3 all that matters
is this little guy can't step another
box all that matters is that it's the
equation we talked about is written
there in that string so purchase
squiggly line this is our I must confess
I actually write a lot R this is how you
write it in R but this literally the
equation that one just means we want to
learn some intercept and we have some
variable is luxury in our data frame
that we're going to learn and and what
we're gonna do and this is an
interesting model so one thing to think
about with this I don't think I actually
wrote this down I kind of wanted to so
one thing to think about with this is
that the way this map works out right so
we're gonna learn some intercepts some B
and is luxury well is luxury is binary
right so it's either 1 or 0 and we think
of how this math is gonna be some number
times 1 or 0 okay we actually I can
write this here I'm really excited to
get to use white for tonight a lot of
whiteboards so so when you think about
what's gonna do on this thing right so
we're gonna have some Y which is our
purchased and it's gonna be equal to
some intercept so some coefficient ham
right times it is luxury almost call it
is like I said I want to write plus some
B okay so the question it might not be
obvious here so how are we gonna learn
about the regular toothbrush and the
logger whose brush from this data so
whatever number this is right and in
this case negative is bad positive is
good I'll explain that in more but this
deaths in general that number the number
that comes out of this is gonna be kinda
hard to interpret right away but this is
just a 0 or a 1 okay
so whatever this number is let's say
it's negative 10 right well if it's not
luxury then this is 0 we don't care
about this right and then all that we're
left with the probability predicting is
just B so this B is gonna be related to
a regular toothbrush because if it's not
luxury it's like regular and if it's not
luxury this thing gets canceled out and
so when it is luxury is this gonna be
whatever this is times 1 plus B so
seems like it's kind of doing this fancy
thing that's really really just
switching these things on and off and so
what this is going to learn this is
luxury this model the coefficients are
on here this M is going to be how
knowing whether it's luxury changes the
outcome so that's why if this M is
negative it means knowing that the
brush's luxury changes the probability
down if it's positive it means it
changes it up so these are gonna be in
this bent space so we're gonna turn them
back to probability so they're gonna be
very large numbers so much larger than 0
or 1 but in general Nestle logic we're
doing here and then we're gonna learn
this intercept this intercept is
actually going to correspond to how well
the regular toothbrush sells it's
actually okay if this is negative it
just means that that's a low rate but
that doesn't mean anything bad in itself
if this M is negative it means that
knowing its luxury hurts your
probability that you're gonna sell so
it's a very different way to look at the
problem in the beta distribution and
initially it's gonna seem kind of
annoying and also it's not clear how
we're going to get certainty out of this
right we want to know this distribution
of our beliefs so that's why we have
Stan out Stan pine MC 3 Stan does the
same stuff so and there's the stand talk
today it's gonna be great
so ok so we run this we run this model
and this is what this is gonna do is
this just gonna try and learn these
coefficients ok and it's gonna learn it
by sampling you can see it's the no
u-turn sampler is the math behind this
is actually quite cool so how this works
is really interesting I definitely can't
get into se but this is really it's what
what pi MC 3 or Stan both do under the
hood is they take that simple equation
and they're gonna they're gonna learn a
district a huge complicated function
this was not huge they learn a function
that represents the space where the
answer could be and they're gonna
literally sample from it in a very
efficient way and this can handle very
complicated models but it's all just
sampling around that space and what its
gonna do is it's gonna example that
space to come up with its estimates for
what these coefficients could be what M
and B could be and M is gonna be called
intercept in this and I mean B is gonna
be called intercept in the results and M
is gonna be called is luxury so don't
worry about this area this is sort of a
diagnostic tool because when you do
these complicated sampling things you
have to watch out for all kinds of
issues but basically these are other
estimates look
like and again these scales are kind of
tricky because we're not in probability
space we're on that bent piece of paper
still so the numbers look a little weird
we're gonna go back don't worry we're
gonna take that paper and unbend it but
you can see what we have here is we have
these distributions and so we have this
intercept where we have all these
possible values what we believe it this
was a sampler found and we have is
laundry which is it and you can see this
is a good example cuz look this is zero
so for this one if it's greater than
zero that means knowing its luxury has a
positive effect on the rate of sale
right because the baseline is what the
regular toothbrush sells that's what
this intercept is that's going to be the
regular toothbrush sale rate again these
numbers are in some other space don't
worry that that's negative and we're
gonna transform them in just a second
but if his luxury is positive that means
that the load of your toothbrush
actually sells better than the regular
one because knowing that it's longer
toothbrush means you believe it's more
likely it's going to sell so we can see
a similar kind of structuring of the
problem we had before but with this
linear model so we can we can do the
same sort of sampling so this is to get
values of is log three we'll say Apple
that and again we can compute the actual
probabilities here this is a different
run of the experiment so don't think
about this result compared to what we
did last in the last notebook because
this is all new data here so in this
case we look at this and we can actually
compute the probability that luxury is
better this way
but it's still hard to reason about this
because we're in this what's called the
log odds space it's just a bent paper
and it's kind of annoying to like think
about this so we have a great image of
this so we're gonna do is we're going to
take this I'm gonna use the logistic so
one survives called logistic regression
we can take this base we can actually
reward that paper back in we can take
these distributions and put them back
into what they look like as
probabilities which is what we just
talked about for an hour so that's what
we want to see so again walk walking
through this sort of equation we want to
start with the log onto the ellow is
four that's the space that we're in so
we're gonna get the samples for the
intercept which is the log Oz of the
regular toothbrush the log odds of the
regular of the luxury toothbrush are the
log odds that is log story plus log onto
the regular right so a little confusing
we're just taking these to distribute
we're mining these back so now we're
going to get a distribution of what our
estimate is for the
luxury and what our estimate is for the
regular does anyone have any questions
on this part no questions that's great
okay so we're here but we're still in
this annoying space but we can use this
logistic function which will turn us
back into probabilities and we get this
which is really cool because this looks
very familiar right it looks almost like
our beta distributions we had before and
if we took in again this is another
round of the experiment so there's also
not the exact same ones we had last time
if you look at the results from the same
beta distribution so this is this this
first graph is this is our linear models
results this is what the model estimates
for what it thinks the rate of sales for
the regular is and the rate of sales for
the luxury if we were to redo it with
beta distributions this is the
distribution we get almost exactly the
same yes
yeah that's a great question I'm glad
you asked that yeah so yeah so because
in the list and this is where the linear
model formula comes in right and this is
where I think about what and it's also
important for us thing about what these
values are
so if if it's not luxury right so is
luxury is an indicator it's a 1 or a 0
that's what's represented as if it is
not luxury then this is 0 and it's gonna
cancel out this M constant right this
coefficient here right and so we get
this so this this base thing is the
model is gonna learn is gonna be
whatever is not luxury which in this
case is regular okay so still where's
some baseline so what the model is
actually on the learn model doesn't know
about the regular toothbrush at all the
model is just saying okay when it's not
luxury we know that that means it's a
regular toothbrush it's gonna say this
is the rate I'm going to try to learn
for that because when it's not luxury
this is zero and then I don't care about
that hem at all the slope doesn't matter
but when when this is one alright
this variable it's sort of poor naming
on my behalf because this is also the
coefficient name when this variable so
the is luxury in this chart and that's
actually I think poor naming on my
behalf this this this is luxury is
really the M not the variable so that's
actually very confusing and I apologize
for that
so we're needs long in this variable
this variable is one I mean that it is
the log of your toothbrush this
coefficient is going to be just what it
is right and it's going to be added to
this base rate which is the rate of the
regular so what we're learning and this
is how we have to structure it refer to
the linear model to work we're learning
the difference between the two so if we
want to know how well the we could just
look at the difference I mean if you
actually want to ask what coming to look
at the difference that actually would be
totally fine to this look at this and
say this is actually all I care about
and that's fine too but if I want to
estimate what the model thinks the the
larger toothbrush is I have to I have to
add what it's estimate for that is to at
estimate for the regular toothbrush
oh I'm sorry that's something yeah so
actually let me immediately however
Sathya that that is confusing yeah so I
kind of went over that very quickly so I
went back and took the data and we can
think of it this way oh I'm sorry the
question was if we're only looking at
the luxury toothbrush and but we're
actually looking at both toothbrushes
combined in this data set so the data
frame is gonna have like a Y and then an
X and the X is gonna be whether is
luxury and then this is gonna be whether
they bought it or not okay sounds like
good synthetic data let's draw some
lines there so this is this is this has
only got two pieces of information in
the model and I really should not have
named the coefficient the same thing as
the variable itself that was very for
naming on my behalf
so yeah so this actually has rather than
separate the data we put it all into one
single thing for the model to learn and
that's what it's different than we did
debated and debated it when we did
debated this revision estimate we looked
at each dataset separately and campus to
separate parameter estimates and we use
those in this case we pushed all the
data together so that this is just the
outcomes for both so it's gonna so if
there's 30 if each thing got turned into
30 we're gonna have 60 rows in this
right because we're gonna combine all of
the rows for the one that was the
regular toothbrush and the regular
toothbrushes it's going to have a 0 here
is we don't need to have an encoding for
regular toothbrush
yeah
oh so the regular toothbrush log-odds is
just this is just this be right so let's
go back to this little thing yes I'm
just getting the values for the
intercepts so it is it's the estimates
for what this is this is what this is
actually is to learn that distribution
for this
we're just taking these samples for what
it thinks this could be all right and
we're adding because we ultimately want
to get the probability of Y right this
represents the probability of Y and so
this is going to give us a distribution
this is what this is gonna give us
distribution so yeah it is that yeah
exactly yeah
yes that's correct yeah yeah oh he just
said that the log odds for luxury is M
plus B mmm mmm plus B in this in this
form is the log odds that's right yeah
yeah so if we if we look at this then
yeah and because this is this is a
binary indicator thing so this is gonna
be either cancel em out or not so the
log odds for luxury is just M plus B
that's right that's correct that's
correct
yeah okay great excellent anyway and
definitely because linear models are
tricky getting getting this in is
actually like I mean the cool thing is
this is a powerful tool because you use
it for all kinds of stuff but actually
yeah these transformations are
non-trivial
and and thinking about the results of
your experiment and especially for this
problem
you're gonna go why in the world would I
not used to pay the distribution one
that was a lot simpler this is a lot
trickier just to wrap your head around I
agree it's a very sort of like okay
what's going on but the interesting
thing I want to point out now so if we
if we go back and we did this the beta
distribution why right the parameter
estimation way this is this is what it
would look like it's almost identical
it's mathematically also almost
identical it's always almost so anyone
that's really a rigorous math Titian in
here if I said these are our identical
they say that's not true you can prove
it the dairy sleigh and the logistic
normal are not the same but they're
close enough and they always will be
close enough so this is a really cool
property to have but again this seems
like a mathematical exercise to do this
why in the world do we have to this
mental contortion to get our data to fit
into a linear model but we will show you
so ya see why do I care so we have two
pencils now a very nice pencil and a
deluxe pencil you can tell the
difference cuz one is got blue and the
other one has red not very different
it's part of the exercise so and they're
not very different right this is a very
nice pencil and this is the deluxe
pencil and so the deluxe pencil is
slightly worse quality a slightly lower
price based on what we've seen so far we
should kind of believe that the deluxe
pencil is probably going to sell better
right because we've seen that people
tend to be a bit more price sensitive
than they are quality sensitive to sort
of looking at this and we wanna test
this to make sure this is so we run this
pencil test a pen test I guess for
security people and then we're gonna get
a whole bunch of samples here we get a
whole bunch of samples cuz the linear
model really likes a lot of samples so
so we do this and we get something is
kind of annoying so in this case let's
go to make sure we got this right
the the very nice pencil is a the Deluxe
pencil is be the the very nice pencil is
a bit more expensive but a bit better
very bit better and the Deluxe pencil is
cheaper so we've run this experiment
should be good but we get this kind of
confusing results we have 2500 samples
and something is not quite right here
we're getting a better estimate for the
toothbrush that does not make sense
right this other pencil the the a
toothbrush pencil a pencil costs more
and it's only a bit better and it
doesn't based on what we've seen I'm not
really comfortable this result so
something seems to be happening here
right and if we if we wait oh yeah so
we're gonna we get my learner's in the
linear model we can repeat this is just
again putting this data into a data
frame we're repeating the last
experiment over again and we get this
and yeah you know it's not like this is
maybe it's uncertainty in our estimate
if we build this linear model we run it
again it's built the same way this is
right we have is the locked pencil we
have an intercept we get this and we go
jeez I mean none of that is really over
zero so it looks like we're very certain
that the lochs pencil is worse there's
actually a good part of your statistical
thinking you should always have kind of
like a sanity check in your head of what
you think the world should look at like
and if the world doesn't look like that
in your statistical test you should ask
why I never ever like look at the output
of a model and like well the model said
what the model says we're done
statistics right and then you see that
half that's what we have a you know the
reproducibility crisis right you should
always be critical statistics because
the tip takes is based on logic it
should always be a logical argument it
should convince you you should be
convinced by your analysis and and so
when you see something like this you go
ah that does not make sense something is
wrong here you should dive deeper rather
than just saying the p-value is really
low I'm done here so you could say that
here but then you'd be wrong because I
know what happened because I designed
this experiment so how do you notice we
actually used a when we ran this
experiment I had a messy experiment
class so that should be a clue that
something it's not quite right here so
so we ran this with this statistic that
failed us at this point and we're
certain it's it's not right so if we
look at the customers this test also
keeps track of what the customer types
were we realize that we have this like
not great it's not all just regular
customers we have these student
customers in here right so if you look
at the car
summers have visited a we got some
students in there and if we look at the
customers that visited B we have some
students there as well and it's not
obvious here if they are different but
we can go ahead and count that up and
there's a lot more students in the B
group so our test was not perfect right
we we showed these pencils to people
these are relatively expensive for a
pretty mediocre pencil if I say so
myself it's high quality so I guess it's
good but so this isn't great now if we
just have the beta distribution we go ha
if what we're gonna do we can throw out
some data maybe we could try to balance
these now it may be just throw the whole
experiment out but this experiment has
gone wrong but we have this information
we know who bought it we know whether
the students are not that purchased it
it's a pretty reasonable assumption to
say well I think students probably at a
lower price threshold than than an
average consumer if a bunch of students
come into a SAS website are you running
and you're trying to sell expensive
software it's not shocking that you're
gonna sell less if it's got more
students but we know there's students we
have some information about this problem
this is really helpful so we can we can
go ahead and we can get this data and
we're gonna concatenate this into a data
frame so our new only we have an eraser
that's very rare to have whiteboard
markers that work and an eraser I think
this is good job Microsoft did a good
job so so we're just concatenate more
complicated now okay I didn't write this
nice top the nice thing is you can kind
of you don't always write these
equations but I think it does help and I
have a whiteboard I'm going to use this
so we're going to do is were gonna make
a new data frame where we have we have
our Y which is whether purchased it or
not we have is deluxe I really should
have named as coefficients different but
once you do any reason why I had made
this mistake is when you do linear malls
enough to kind of internalize this
thinking you like I know I care about
the coefficient I'm just gonna need to
call them the same that's a coefficient
and and you do that so we have instant
logs we also have is student is student
so we're gonna have we're gonna have as
indicator it's very easy exactly like
the last one indicating whether it's is
the deluxe pencil and we also now have
this one that will let us know
as a student so this is actually pretty
cool so now we have a bit more
information and we have the same
property because it's this binary
indicator right and this is a pretty
common thing you'll see when you're
doing statistical test is sort of you
just know whether something is true or
not and it has this nice property that
the term drops out when it's zero which
is super convenient right so now we have
three things we're gonna learn well
we'll stop the intercepts which is gonna
tell us something about well we're gonna
learn these things we're gonna learn the
intercept from this we're gonna learn
some coefficient for is delux and we're
gonna learn some coefficient for his
student and we're gonna learn some
intercepts and the intercept is gonna be
the rate of what happens when the pencil
when the pencil is the very good pencil
very nice pencil if the lochs is going
to be the difference from when we know
is Deluxe pencil and student is going to
be the difference between oh it's a
student so we're gonna learn three
things this time and you can think of
how these are all added right if it's
not deluxe and it's not a student we
just get the rate of the of the very
nice pencil when we try to sell it if it
is deluxe
but it's not student we're gonna get we
add this and this we're gonna get the
rate of it being a deluxe pencil selling
if it's deluxe and it is student the
students gonna tell us how much the
students impacted this and so what we're
gonna learn is actually a whole bunch of
stuff which is really cool I'm just
gonna run this so you can see it so you
can see here's our here's our thing
here's our equation right and yeah
actually that is why I named them this
way because I think about it's actually
it's confusing for learning right so
those are the column names it's gonna
look for in the data in the data frame
so that is very helpful that the column
names be the coefficients but they're
really like the it's the x is the data
frame column and the coefficient is
separate thing so that's interesting I
never thought about that so we're gonna
run this and we're gonna get these which
is really really cool so the intercept
really don't care about it just tells us
what the rate is our estimate for that
rate and is deluxe is now all positive
right so we're not gonna convert these
back into I don't believe I do
yeah we're not gonna convert these back
to log probabilities don't have to for
this one but we can see that because
Deluxe is all positive it
the deluxe choose brush as we suspected
is entirely a positive impact on a sale
and the students we have this sort of
broad at distribution there but now we
have this estimate that students is all
a negative interaction which makes sense
so now we've been able to take this
linear model which extends what we did
with that you know it's very when we
decided to replace two parameter
estimates it was annoying to use a
linear model didn't make any sense but
now this little complexity in our
experiment design we can now resolve it
and we the cool thing is we actually
learned not only do we uncover that the
deluxe crease brush probably is better
right now that we've been able to
account for their student population we
also now have information about how well
do students purchase pencils right this
is this is this assumes someone catching
this right as it assumes that the
student purchasing behavior is
independent of the of the actual pencil
itself right they just have some sort of
fixed rate that they hurt sales but out
of this now we had a test that looks
like it was a flawed test that we had to
throw out but now we actually got all
this information about how students
behaved as well so we have estimates for
that we now the deluxe pencil is a bit
better because as we expect it it's a
bit cheaper and it should be better and
also that students are worse and we
could we could go ahead and throw these
into we could transform them logistic
and do the beta distribution on these
and and see that day so this is the very
very beginning of we can generalize on
your model but it is a question yeah no
it's a great question I mean I think
you're right yeah it is it is it is it
is drawing yeah you're absolutely right
you are learning this much more complex
thing right yeah because we can think of
this as we don't have to think this is a
vector right if you like a machine
learning we would put this as one big X
I mean have these coefficients and we
separate them out so it's easier to read
but yeah we are getting this sort of
multi-dimensional situation and if
you're if you're asking does it get
complicated there yes it does like you
can definitely get already it's kind of
it is tricky to sort of figure out
what's actually happening right
luli in here we're basically going from
two-dimensional space to some 3d
possibly and yeah what's still well what
still is linear what's nice is it still
just gives us the rate right so the the
ultimate thing is what we're getting is
so when I put that why there we're
really learning the probability of of
that purchase right that's ultimately
we're learning the log odds of the
probability so when we remember that way
just solve the equation for whatever
information we have we the answer that
gives us is the log odds or a
transformed version of the probability
of Y we can draw more we can throw them
on the whiteboard let me yeah this is
this is really this is really tricky you
know we actually are this is we're done
and we still have 10 minutes so yeah I
wouldn't actually we're actually you can
so let me just write this out and then
did you have a question real quick is it
oh this is this formula right here this
Sendak oh yeah so this is this is like
shorthand for this oh yeah this is it so
in the data frame here in this pencil
test data there is a column called this
deluxe there's a column called purchased
and there's a column called is student
and the one just means I care about the
intercept you actually I do not believe
need to put the 1 there it will always
have an intercept but the 1 is just
notationally there so is that is that
correct I see sticking fit yeah I always
put it there because I want to make sure
that it's there so this means that we're
gonna we have an intercept right it's um
it's gonna learn some coefficient times
1 and it's always gonna be one you don't
have to put it there it'll do it for you
yes exactly yeah so this is this is yeah
I always found this kid I actually found
our syntax very confusing yeah so what
that's what that is is it's and it's
tricky because it's this string right so
in the data frame there and this'll
actually as I write this out I can help
answer your question the same time so
this is a great combined thing yeah so
this is and you'll see the
this notation comes up in our line this
way really helps sort of stretch these
things so in pencil test data we have a
purchase column is the locks column and
is student column so what we're learning
is some I can't spell okay good I was
awful at spelling in like all of grade
school and I thought that would not be a
problem as an adult but it's like number
one coding error I've ever had is typos
and I really feel like I can't believe
that like primary school was right so so
what this is this is this is actually as
confusing notation so it's gonna learn a
coefficient for each of these and just
like me it's gonna name them poorly so
I'm trying to think notation having
makes more sense so these are the values
that are going in okay you can think of
this as the values right so there's a
one which is gonna be just all ones it's
gonna learn some m0 of one so to learn
some coefficient m4 the one this
squeedily just means equal because we
don't wanna use equals all the time it's
just a convention so that's quits but it
looks very magic I first saw this movie
I was like well what's that squiggly all
about yeah yeah yeah or you need to be
fair to be fair if we want to be really
technical right we could talk about the
squirrely kind of implies that it's
being sampled from this distribution so
it's not your is alright so yeah I
shouldn't say that you can ignore this
squiggly equals thing yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah
and so this quickly actually does often
in notation mean it's being sampled from
some distribution so so it is you I do
want to correct that don't just
translate that as equals for weird
reasons the reason why is that you can
as you if you use more and more Stan or
PI MC 3 you'll see that squiggly and
that's really usually means especially a
notation it means that it's coming from
sort of so squiggly like normal means
it's coming from a normal distribution
it doesn't mean that it's a fixed value
so there's some distribution of
parameters here that's a lot to dive
into but for practical for thinking this
through that's what the equal sign goes
in your equation so yeah so what is
happening under the hood it's gonna
learn m 0 times 1 plus
and one x is deluxe this is my time my
dot its deluxe plus m2 times is student
so so these the reason why it's a one is
one times it's always be one times this
coefficient which is the same thing as
just having that that's why this is
gonna be the intercept so yeah this is
gonna be B yeah yeah so it's learning
these as each coefficients and but when
you think about this B times a constant
value it's always going to be the same
right it has no you just gonna learn
some consistent thing there so that's
what that's gonna be and then so for
this and this gets so this is and then I
have a blog post that does go a lot more
detail but this this represents a linear
version of our probability right so this
is not actually a binary at all this is
going to be some number that when we do
the logistic gives us the probability of
purchased give in the data we have which
is a bit more nuanced so you're actually
learning a probability of purchased
rather than a binary purchase there's
not a threshold here so you're gonna
learn these coefficients still so if in
the case where this is always gonna be
one right because there's no data being
input here when it is delux and it is a
student this is gonna learn it's gonna
multiply whatever the penalty for being
a penalty reward for being insta Luxus
plus the penalty reward for being a
student right and you add them out
you're gonna get this and you're gonna
transform it and it's gonna give you the
probability the only reason that these
annoying transformation is because
otherwise it wouldn't be linear so we
need to have that that's a generalized
linear model part of it but basically
this is gonna be some this is gonna
represent how much this hurts or
benefits and you can keep going forever
right you can add more and more and more
things the tricky thing is it this model
this is where is the linear model and
just like it's a regular linear
regression you have a sort of weaknesses
right where you can you can see them
more easily in linear amount in a
traditional linear model but the the
issue is it doesn't this model does not
account for the fact that maybe students
really like Deluxe pencil for some other
reason right this model assumes that
students buy pencils at a lower or
higher rate in
dependent of everything else about the
pencils and so that something had to
keep in mind especially for experiment
design so if this deluxe pencil said
like I hate students on it then this is
not really gonna be correct right
if there's some reason why students
would be like one time says it hates me
yeah right exactly exactly yeah this is
not a pencil I want so there are all
kinds of assumptions in here so you know
but this is this is a framework when you
think about this you can start asking
all kinds of more and more complicated
questions you could have a whole bunch
of demographic information and then
you're gonna get estimates about all the
demographic information which is which
is pretty cool so and then this is where
if you're a machine learning person like
we don't even care about this I don't
care about the outcome you can write if
you're trying to like come up with some
some risk you want to have right if you
want to have an if you want to be like
what's the you know we want to only we
want to put a promotion on the website
but only if there's a greater than 20%
chance that the person is gonna buy the
product right you might want to do this
what are the homeworks actually is so
these are discrete things right these
are binary things we we've seen that we
have this quality and this quantity
right so we could think about this
problem a little bit differently we
could we could ignore all these other
things we've seen and we could we could
generate a whole bunch of products right
and we could say okay given its quality
and its price learn some coefficients
there I think that too right and now you
actually have this model that says okay
I need this to sell twice as much the
rate this is where this is where these
things get really interesting it's get
really powerful this one people talk
about interpretable models versus
explainable models this is an
interpretable model because if you
modeled Brian let's say a whole bunch of
products here right we just seen a
toothbrush in the pencil we know that
price seems to be more important than
quality we don't know exactly how they
work but you can actually start learning
exactly how they work so you could
generate in this example or in real life
take the products you have with a whole
bunch of different prices right and you
could say you did it sell or did it not
based on just its price and its quality
and then these will give you how those
affect things so you might say I need to
you can answer it really kind this is
like when the homework question so you
can answer questions like I need to sell
20%
of these I know that price has an impact
on this if you can learn exactly how
price has an impact you can learn
exactly how you have to change the price
to increase the chance that you'll sell
by 20% yeah so yeah exactly yeah great
great so the syntax of that so we'd
still have so we'd have to have a data
frame that had purchased and quality
columns right and it's totally fine if
they're they're numbers so that would be
let's actually look so I don't mess up
so yeah there's the purchase that would
be if we have the data frame we pass in
it has those things it's gonna be pushed
this is my quotes purchased squiggly
tilled one new put the one anywhere I
believe one plus so I know I'm working
there anymore price whenever the
assuming that practice the the data
frame column for that and quality and
these these actually would be you know
continuous values which would be
interesting is it will now this is where
you get into all the complexity of
linear modeling cuz you might say well
will you told me these can be between 0
and 5 well now it's a different problem
but if you assume these are sort of both
continuous things you can even so this
this would be it this would be that
would be all of it though the answer
your question that would be that and
then what you get out is you
distributions for both of those and you
could see and again it's hard to
interpret those distributions but
getting back to what you were saying you
could go in and say okay so I have a
thing that I know is a five-star quality
item and it's currently $20 and it's not
selling so you can put this in put that
there you're gonna get a distribution of
what the rate of sales is based on what
you've learned for that particular thing
which is kind of cool and then you can
say what if I made it 18 how much more
would it sell you could actually make
that 18 recalculate this and you're
going to get another distribution of
predictions for that or you're gonna get
a point estimate but you can get a
distribution if you want so the stuff
becomes really powerful and that's where
like I said people when people go on
about interpretability then this is this
is inference right so you talk about
there's prediction in machine learning
and there's
inference and this is the inference
problem and you can see what we're doing
is we're kind of reverse engineering
reality right we're really trying to
figure out how things work and we have
to use these simple models
we can this is why you know if you if
you're talking to a statistician and
they're like gosh why is using a neural
network it's because you can't make it
model using a neural network that makes
sense to you and me
alright so for certain problems we have
to do that like I don't really know how
language works I don't think language
works as a linear model so we use
machine learning to do that but for
these type of things especially for a
Greg Euler business problems this is
kind of logic we want to use because we
wanted to say things like okay if we get
wait for actually one of the big
problems we have is we want to show
products more and see if that helps them
sell more it doesn't always work so you
can actually see how is that work you
can actually mom I've run experiments
where I model these things as more you
can actually model interactions which I
don't wanna get into but you can
multiply two of these things and then
actually tell us how they interact with
each other so if you wanted to see if
students buy a pencil differently
because it's a deluxe pencil is mean
towards students you can actually put
that in your model and learn that
there's really really no limit to how
far you can go with this stuff
but of course as you get more
complicated you run into more problems
and there's more catches to everything
yeah exactly exactly exactly in which
and I don't want to give this but this
actually is another question if you
wanted to model that in this notation
you can you could do plus there's a
great book called statistical rethinking
if you want to go really deep it's in
our there's a whole Python set up sup
and he really covers this much better
than Africa is really excellent book for
going to details of this stuff price
times quality this is gonna be really
tricky because it's gonna don't do this
at home yet read more about it but to
answer your question this would actually
do that so this is gonna learn a
coefficient for these two things times
each other I believe this is correct
right okay thank you
so so yeah so this and this is and so
what you're gonna learn is going on a
third coefficient which is the
interaction of these two now this is
tricky because you're learning how price
affects it how quality affects it and
then the way price and quality work so
maybe you want to get rid of some of
these and just learn this interaction
that's gonna be kind of weird so there's
a lot of different ways you can do this
as a loss it gets really complicated and
then this isn't even touch on the true
power of like Bayesian inference because
you can learn even more about how all
these things interact there's no limit
to to this yeah so yeah yeah actually
that gets a good point so at the very
least if it if it hovers around zero you
can say these things aren't related how
are you gonna pick that apart when it's
not zero is not easy you actually the
typical advice is to actually and this
is way beyond the scope of stuff but you
can actually sample since you have these
two distributions you can run the model
backwards and get uncertainty about all
of your estimates but if you want to
know when these when these interactions
appear
you really have to sample from the data
that sort of get a feel for how it's
doing it really is hard to just
interpret so for these simple ones you
can do you know for testing purposes
these sort of simple things like this is
actually even more this is more
complicated and you want to do on a test
right is it giving you a lot of
information but in this simple case you
could at least say is reading you know
what and you can you can see which is
more important price quality obviously
from what we've seen it seems a quality
is less important than price seems to be
the big push for people so and this
model would probably learn that example
from enough examples of things that had
different prices and qualities the model
will give you estimates for these and my
guess would be that this coefficient
would be in general lower magnitude of
an impact than this would that price is
going to have a more strong impact on
the sales oh we are at 10:30 thank you I
have a blog to count Phase II and I
wrote a book on this stuff so in order
Haskell book thank you so much